[ Knock on door ]
-Yo!
-Hey, Matthew.
-Hey, Jimmy.
Merry Christmas, man.
Happy holidays.
-Happy holidays. Any big plans?
-Oh, yes.
I'm going home to spend some
quality time with my family.
-Yeah, same.
I can't believe
it's been two years
since we got to celebrate
Christmas together.
-Right? I know, I can't wait to
see everyone.
-I know.
I'll tell you one thing though.
This year's going to be
a lot different than last one.
-It sure will, Jimmy.
♪ This Christmas
will be different ♪
♪ Than Christmas
from last year ♪
-♪ We're trading
in the FaceTimes ♪
♪ For some in-person cheer ♪
♪ I can't wait to see them ♪
♪ The sights and sounds ♪
-♪ This Christmas, we're flying
back to our hometown ♪
-Excuse me.
-Hey!
-Sorry.
-Out of the way.
-Excuse me, hey!
-Hey!
Excuse me. Let's go!
♪ There's always
that one neighbor ♪
♪ Who goes way too hard
with his lights ♪
-Hey, Matthew.
-Hey.
♪ And your mama
tells the family ♪
♪ About every little
neighborhood fight ♪
-There is book-club drama.
-♪ And your aunt pulls you
underneath the mistletoe ♪
♪ And even though
we're vaccinated ♪
♪ That is still a big no ♪
-♪ Then you cuddle in bed
at the end of the night ♪
♪ But it's your childhood bed ♪
♪ You got to share with
your wife ♪
-Could you scoot over
like two inches?
-Uh, I can't.
This bed's a racecar.
-♪ This Christmas
will be different ♪
♪ Than Christmas
from last year ♪
-♪ Somebody check on uncle ♪
♪ That's like his seventh beer ♪
-♪ Let's not talk politics ♪
♪ No need to fight ♪
♪ Let's make this Christmas ♪
♪ Alright, alright, alright ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ All the kids are playing with
new toys ♪
-♪ Carolers are bringing joy ♪
-♪ Throwing an ornament
on the tree ♪
-♪ Build a snowman
in the yard with friends ♪
-♪ Last-minute gifts from CVS ♪
-♪ Uh, my secret Santa clearly
does not know me ♪
Really?
-That's all they had.
Hook 'em?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ But my favorite part
of the holiday ♪
♪ Is when we gather
to all sing along ♪
♪ To our favorite
Christmas song ♪
-We can do that right now.
-We can?
-Yeah.
Come on, let's all sing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ The snow's coming down ♪
♪ I'm watching it fall ♪
♪ Lots of people around ♪
♪ Baby, please come home ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ All the church bells
in town ♪
♪ Yeah, they're ringing a song ♪
♪ What a sweet, sweet sound ♪
♪ Baby, please come home ♪
-♪ They're singing
"Deck the Halls" ♪
♪ But it's not like Christmas
at all ♪
-♪ I remember
when you were here ♪
♪ And all the fun we had
that year ♪
-♪ If there was a way ♪
♪ I'd hold back these tears ♪
-♪ But it's Christmas Day ♪
-♪ Baby, baby, baby ♪
-♪ Baby, please come home ♪
♪ Baby, please come home ♪
♪ Baby, baby, baby, baby ♪
-♪ Baby, baby,
please come home ♪
-♪ Baby, please come home ♪
-♪ Oh, oh ♪
-♪ Won't you? ♪
-♪ Christmastime ♪
♪ Baby, please come home ♪
My thanks to
Matthew McConaughey!
My thanks to Haim!
We'll be right back with
more "Tonight Show"!
-♪ Please, please come home ♪
-♪ Baby, baby ♪
-♪ Please come home ♪
♪ Baby, please come home ♪
♪ Oh, oh, baby,
please come home ♪
♪ I say, baby, baby,
please come home now ♪
♪ Please come home now ♪
♪ Won't you please come home
now? ♪
♪ Won't you please come home? ♪
♪ Baby, baby, please come, come,
come hoooooooome ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]